à l'autre bout du monde des touristes un
peu fou s'en vont passer leurs vacances
au pied des volcans mais qui sont ils et
que viennent ils chercher
cette histoire commence par un matin
d'hiver à betschdorf en alsace des
moutons des champs de labour on a encore
bien loin des volcans et pourtant pas
tant que ça je me prépare parce que là
ça va grimper fort et je me sens plutôt
assez sûr de moi donc c'est plus
rassurant partir dans ces conditions et
avec l'exigence un volcan à cette heure
de monter
la toile
pour la famille rustenholz les volcans
c'est une vieille histoire une histoire
aux allures de romance à l'italienne
c'est une histoire qui a commencé quand
on n'était même pas mariés mais 20 ans
moi ça a été un vrai coup de foudre nous
on était le stromboli par hasard on sait
pas ce que c'était on y à peine
d'arriver en haut le truc il a explosé
et je me suis carapater d'ailleurs un
grand rocher parce que j'aime ça tombait
30 mètres de nous
comment tu le vois le voyage avec ses
parents ça va être une sacrée aventure
chaud non franchement ça va être bien
moi j'ai hâte de d'aller sous d'autres
horizons avec eux ça va devenir
dans quelques jours pascal michelle et
leur fille pauline s'envoleront pour les
volcans d'indonésie
au couteau suisse tu l'as
couteau
mask ha gazh couteau il ne faut rien
oublier et surtout pas les petites
douceurs pour les moments difficiles
oublier la convivialité
vraiment important le carburant du
voyage
on emmène toujours à 50 chez nous quoi
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
dans la famille blonde et on prépare
aussi un grand voyage dans quelques
jours pascal partira à la découverte des
volcans d'ethiopie en afrique
j'y passais choses en face ils sont là
ils sont dans sa femme à ce rite a une
fois de plus ce ne sera pas du voyage je
vous envoie ce qu'on voulait partir
un petit peu et merrill et d'habitude il
est le maintien
ça fait 15 ans qu'ils essaient avec
pascal je comprends sa passion
voilà mais pour moi j'y vais pas
la peur c'est vraiment le moteur du
voyage la peur je dirais il a prévu mais
le fait de ne pas savoir ce qu'on va
trouver est ce qu'on va trouver du joli
spectacle est ce que cette moyens est-ce
qu'on va avoir un nouveau type
d'activité c'est vraiment le moteur du
voyageur et voilà
pascal est ingénieur une vie bien rangée
mais pour tuer de ce qu'il appelle ses
petites aventures car derrière se
profile plutôt discret se cache un
chasseur d'image
pascal a gravi plus de 50 cratère à
travers le monde parmi les plus
dangereux d'entre eux là on a faim on a
vraiment failli rester parce que là on
était en train de fuir
ben en fait les gens étaient
complètement perdus je n'y voyais plus
rien les essuie glaces avaient du mal à
dégager le pare brise
ça c'est vraiment la photo
ça vaut le une photo avec le sommet du
merapi
dès qu'un volcan se manifeste pascal
fait ses valises et justement en
ethiopie l'erta ale a montré quelques
signes de réveil alors il n'y a plus un
moment à perdre
[Musique]
le désert éthiopien pour pascal la
jungle tropicale de l'indonésie pour les
russes la noise
après douze mille kilomètres de vol 24
heures de trajet
les voilà enfin dans l'archipel des
moluques sûr
[Musique]
l'archipel des moluques à barriques 16
volcan est parmi les plus actifs de la
planète
cela c'est aussi le territoire de tout
un peuple les mines à ça les gens
souriants
l' aventure ne pouvait mieux commencer
[Musique]
au pied du volcan la terre
exceptionnellement fertile à attirer les
populations de toute la région
à l'ombre des cratères les marchés
abonde de fruits et de légumes exotiques
pascal michel et pauline ils font leurs
premiers pas emmenés par robbie leur
guide francophone
m
[Musique]
les odeurs de vacances que vous aimez
ouais ouais ouais les couleurs les
odeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le marché c'est l'endroit où tu dois il
prend le plus compact avec la réalité
d'un pays surtout quand c'est un marché
local marshall
bizarre c'est très bon vous savez
oui ça a l'air très bon oui
[Rires]
aux moluques les volcans ne sont jamais
très loin et pour se faire une meilleure
idée du site il suffit de prendre un peu
de hauteur c'est un tableau
très lourd
toutes les îles qui sont en sortie c'est
que du volcan bon train il y en a tant
dormi
[Rires]
des cratères endormi des plages désertes
et des lagon bleu turquoise le pays des
volcans a pour l'instant des airs de
paradis pour notre famille d'aventuriers
dr du danakil en ethiopie c'est l'un des
endroits les plus chauds de la planète
ici la température flirte avec les 50
degrés à l'ombre quand il y en a
les hommes récolte le sel
pascal lui chasse les images
[Musique]
c'est pas trahi que j'aimerais faire en
plein cagnard en plein soleil et foncent
à toute la journée parce que je pense
qu'après une heure je serais mort
c'est presque au centimètre près
le sel c'est l'une des seules richesses
des hommes du désert on charge sur les
dromadaires depuis des millénaires
la salle un vrai voyage dans le temps
trois plaques tectoniques déchire le sol
éthiopien au fil du temps elles ont fait
apparaître de nombreux volcans pascal
est venu voir deux d'entre eux le dal
hall et le mythique erta ale
nous sommes aux portes du territoire à
fars les cratères tant convoitées sont
là à quelques heures de route juste
derrière ces collines
en attendant de les rejoindre pascal
retrouve son ami guy de saint-cyr ils
organisent ce voyage
dit travaille ici depuis 15 ans un
baroudeur réputé qui connaît les tuyaux
qui comme sa poche elle date de quand
c'est là la vraie attend facial elle a
fait écouter premier voyage ici non pas
les attend respecte sur le capot
et on vient d'arriver ici à paris donc à
partir de là on rentre dans tes doigts
phare donc dans une zone hostile dans
une zone dont là on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir un accident on n'a pas le droit
rend compte que sur nous ici donc il
faut faire attention parce que là c'est
une lourde qui est dangereuse pour plein
de raisons
soldats en armes checkpoint le
territoire afar et sous haute
surveillance
c'est une zone sensible où les
frontières sont disputés
lafare s'étend sur trois pays l'ethiopie
l'erythrée et djibouti
il est impossible de traverser la zone
sans escorte militaire
sur le terrain les afars contrôler toute
la région y compris l'accès au volcan
lisa c'est le chiffre de toute la région
a pas tout passe par lui toutes les
autorisations passe par une
traversée la fin ça qu'on n'a pas été
voir ça
yama temps vous savez beaucoup de
visiteurs du monde entier viennent nous
voir nous on s'occupe de leur sécurité à
tous points de vue
tu sais qui tu es mon amie on se connaît
depuis longtemps maintenant ici tout le
monde tu apprécies
c'est anton au nord que j'appelais mon
fils comme toi donc tu seras toujours le
bienvenu ici
guillemot
vous êtes tous nos invités
pathé live vous êtes les invités du
peuple afar merci merci
merci à toi
merci
il faut de la patience il faut négocier
avec quelques billets glissés y faire et
sans lui les portes de la fare resterait
fermé
pascal est soulagé le voyage continue
[Musique]
depuis 1933 le volcan du cône au crash
son panache de fumée les habitants et
les scientifiques garde un oeil dessus
ce matin les relevés ne montre rien
d'anormal
la famille russe times va pouvoir
approcher son sommet
facile à dire
maintenant ça commence on entrait dans
la forêt alors en des fois il ya des
fourmis qui sont méchants il ya des
mygales il ya des terrains autour des
fois il ya des serpents
j'aime pas trop aux ajustements ont
croisé
des choix de sang
il faut s'enfoncer dans une jungle dense
et sauvage
leduc ono ne s'offre pas au premier venu
c'est pas des chemins balisés de se
faufiler entre les liens
en dessous des troncs par dessus les
drom
c'est super sympa super excitant
je me sens pas cette histoire c'est par
là robbie
aller mais les
attends je vais y aller tant attendu
incroyable
croyable
et alors là aux premières loges
s'il fait
si
leduc au no c'est d'abord un bruit sourd
et constant ce sont des nuées ardentes
et des bombes volcaniques qui explosent
à tout moment ça tu vas vraiment mis en
activité toi qui les vignes on
passe quelque chose là ou quoi
ce soir le groupe va passer la nuit à
deux kilomètres du cratère sur un
immense tapis de cendres bah c'est bien
pour moi ici c'est bien aussi il ya des
anges et être aussi proche
[Musique]
on n'a pas peur
pas le rouge
c'est un peu technique ils ont tendance
à s'engueuler et puis chez entre alors
faut que je fasse ça sera pas plein de
gens font bruit savante là dedans ce
match à fond
ça me rappelle la jeunesse a pour part
tes sacs haut doubs il qu'on allait déjà
avoir le volcan en retournant on
retourne au point de départ
en ethiopie pascal et guy font route
vers le volcan pas d'ascension mais une
marche à travers les canyon de sel pour
atteindre cet endroit unique au monde le
dal hall
un volcan dont le sommet culmine en
dessous du niveau de la mer bon allez
venez regarder
voilà le site de dole
dallol c'est comme une palette de
couleurs pour les enfants 20 ans sortait
mars 14
une palette de couleurs en constante
évolution et qui au delà des apparences
veut se montrer tout à coup beaucoup
moins attirante
il ya des croûtes de souffre qui sont
très fines et sous sa croûte fine il ya
de l'acide
donc à partir de là vraiment on se suit
si vous voyez disparaître vous arrêter
voilà ce que je veux du gourou
c'est un mélange d'acide de vapeurs de
soufre et de méthane le genre de mélange
qui nécessite de bien regarder où l'on
va poser ses pieds
bon on va tromper le papier ph là pour
voir le taux d'acidité le potentiel
hydrogène et de l'acide
voyez que la couleur c'est entre 0 et 1
sauber c'est de la cedh vu
le cratère dallol a été recouvert par le
sel au fil du temps c'est ce celle qui a
créé ses formes et ses couleurs et qui
désormais attire toute l'attention de
notre photographe
des boules de meringue comme ça au bout
de glace coco
température ambiante ça me fait du bien
c'est un petit bout las coco sur un jeu
par jean valjean omelette norvégienne
voilà à quoi me fait penser dalle
là je suis content parce qu'ils ont tous
regardent ils ont tous des grands
sourires ils ont les yeux qui pétillent
voilà ça c'est d'abord
la question pensent à ça sans faute
bravo
effectivement voilà ce qu'on cherche
mousser sa du vert du jaune de l'ordre
du blanc l'éventail de preneurs
fantastique c'est ça le but du voyage
en ethiopie il y a des incontournables
pour des visiteurs comme pascal la
dégustation du café
[Musique]
la légende raconte même qu'il a été
découvert ici pour la première fois il y
a plus de 500 ans
[Musique]
chaque fois que je viens ici tu prends
le café ouais c'est une tradition si je
vous aime pas ils sont vexés
[Musique]
et on ressent déjà l'odeur et après on
l'écrasé et après le cap et au petit
noir ça prend une heure
[Musique]
mais alors il est bon et délicieux d'y
remédier a que ça qui a fait fermer
gamour
en indonésie nous à la science célèbrent
à leur façon leur première nuit sur le
volcan
[Musique]
ce sont des rêves encore de notre
jeunesse souhaite
revenir
mais là où
on va se tromper de temps ça va être
avec vous j'envoie 103 familles
[Musique]
des pics iront ce soir la nuit sera
courte
[Musique]
il est deux heures du matin il faut se
lever tôt pour espérer atteindre le
sommet au lever du soleil
on y va
en pleine nuit sur un tas de cendres
les voilà à flanc de volcan éclairée par
la lampe torche un pas devant l'autre et
tout ira bien
to move artères d'impression ainsi
seulement 70 du chocolat mais tu as
l'impression d'être sur la lune ici réel
dans ses minutes on ira en sommet au
pôle des cratères alors s'il vous plaît
vous conseille mettez votre casque voilà
si on prend des cailloux sur la tête et
ottawa
avant
oh
ça c'est la cocotte-minute heures tu as
l'impression d'approcher l'antre des
dragons
le sol vibre le bruit est assourdissant
l'endroit est invivable et pourtant les
russes la noise semble dans leur élément
[Musique]
on commençait à avoir un petit bout du
veau et la joie
fermer la bouche on peut lire un peu
temps
pour être carrément
là on est dans la marmite bouillonnante
du centre de
l'intersaison direct ses lunettes et une
aile qui descend direct au centre de la
terre mais ça c'est du fantasme
le jour se lève sur le duc ono la brume
va-t-elle laisser entrevoir le fond du
cratère
pascal michel et pauline ne sont pas au
bout de leurs surprises
après deux heures de marche dans la nuit
et dans la cendre la famille rustenholz
vient d'atteindre le sommet du duc onovo
mais le cratère se cache encore derrière
les nuages
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant
vraiment dommage qu'on puisse pas voir à
l'intérieur du cratère et que
j'ai imaginé
il pleure
le lever du soleil chasse enfin la brume
est sur la crête ce sont de drôles de
visages qui apparaissent en sorte de la
mine
lundi d'erreur
il tu vois bien que je souris
attention bien huilé cédiez blanc
en bas la vision est terrifiante du
grand spectacle comme seule la nature
est capable d'en offrir
plett m'en irai
hélas
mais l'air est irrespirable
il faut se résigner à redescendre le
voyage des rues steens promet encore
d'autres émotions d'autres rencontres
en attendant loin du chaos des cratères
on se laisse un peu aller au rythme de
la vie du peuple des volcans
[Musique]
pour moi qui suis pas trop chargée
en ethiopie le grand voyage vers l'erta
ale se prépare dans quelques heures
pascal et guy seront livrés à eux mêmes
loin de tout
c'est quand même un environnement assez
hostile il n'y a pas d'eau on va rester
là où comme de jour donc c'est
et vraiment bien préparé son sac ne rien
oublier parce que une folle et là haut
c'est fini
ici la légende raconte que des esprits
road et ferait disparaître les
promeneurs perdu alors chacun garde un
oeil sur l'autre qui plus est quand il
s'agit de marcher sur de la lave c'est
chez vous ai toujours trouvé un petit
peu d espace pas cela on va arriver dans
une zone où les délais sont assez
fragiles évitez d'avoir deux personnes
sur le même talent guy ouvre la voie ils
l'ont connaît le tracé par coeur chaque
pierre chaque falaise
et puis au détour d'un rocher le voilà
le mythe sickert à aller des lacs de
lave comme celui ci il n'y en a que
quatre sur la planète
est aujourd'hui comme espéré il est en
pleine activité
c'est magnifique 1
ouf la plaçant la chaleur ou
vous la formule est un peu
attends là j'ai les mains qui craint et
l'appareil aussi choix est aussi ce qu
on appelle le mur de chaleur le mur
chaleur terre dès qu'on dépasse ce mur
de chaleur qui est très nette la chaleur
rayonnante brûle il se mure chaleur le
sang frais nettement là il est pas loin
si on dépasse encore de quelques
dizaines de centimètres ça y est on est
bouché
et c'est pas fini là il va y en avoir
encore toute la ville à vous le voyez
toujours mais vous allez voir quand la
vue va tomber c'est encore un autre
spectacle
ont fait confiance ça va
en ethiopie en indonésie la nuit promet
d'être inoubliable
la famille restée noces peut-être
premières loges pour admirer le
spectacle du volcan hibou
mélo à rien
hibou un autre volcan très actif qui
génèrent de manière continue explosion
et nuées ardentes
[Musique]
c'est un peu inquiétant la toune
tu as des bruits le brouillard tu sais
pas ce qui s'est mal s'ils arrivent à
une énorme explosion et bien il ya
toutes les pierres qui retombe et ça
fait un bruit incroyable d'être au top
10 secondes il a explosé
en fait on attend on attend
ça fait neuf mois que j'attends ça une
fois neuf mois que j'en rêve mais
maintenant on y est arrivés on va voir
du rouge santander
c'est pas tomber l'oiseau
on est on est proches ont dû s'acquiter
mais avec le brouillard avec le
brouillard on verra la nuit encore on
fait râler mais voilà
la nuit tombe sur le bivouac
d'un côté les alsaciens attend de
l'accalmie pour observer les explosions
de l'autre les porteurs de l'expédition
se repose pour eux le spectacle ce ne
sont pas les volcans mais c'est drôle
d'aventuriers
la première fois que ce volcan s'est
réveillé on ne comprenait pas pourquoi
des étrangers voulaient à tout prix
monter
c'était très dangereux mais les
touristes y allait quand même nous on se
demandait si ses jours n'étaient pas
complètement fou
à
l'époque on pensait que les touristes
qui montait sur le volcan j'y allais
pour le calmer pour l'étendre dépasser
mais en fait ça n'était pas du tout le
cas
[Rires]
[Musique]
entre temps le bruit
c'est quelque chose incroyable quand on
est là on attend désespère pas explosé
puis d'un coup paf et l'explosion
j'ai attrapé violence ça donne envie
d'en voir plus et je pense qu'il ya
vraiment moyen de faire les très beaux
voyages dans deux pays
e sympa de pouvoir partager les émotions
comme ça en famille et je pense que
il
on peut pas s'en passer quand on a
commencé un goûter ça c'est impossible
elle regarde ce spectacle coquin volta
50 ans ça fait cinquante six ans que je
fréquente des volcans j'ai rien inventé
rien découvert mais par contre ils vont
communiquer une force une passion un
bonheur que personne toutes ont été
capables de nous communiquer
et grâce à eux j'ai impression vraiment
d'avoir réussi ma vie
[Musique]